hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video ich kriege ja selber relativ
häufig bitte den kommentaren und zwar
stand einfach eine lange zeit dieses
gerücht im raum ob ich jetzt mit
freundin habe ich keine freundin habe ob
ich single bin vergeben und evra bleibt
der regen habe ich mir gedacht ich lüfte
das geheimnis der zuschnitt blesendorf
renntag das soll wirklich gar nicht so
ein schwachsinn sein lied schon mal
gemacht und auf meinen kanal hier schon
mal das hatte ich nur im kumpel max
damals so dargestellt martina soll auf
jeden fall überhaupt nicht diesmal so
gestellt sein sondern wirklich ich zeige
euch jetzt mal eine freundin mitnehmen
zusammen diesen golf renntag auf und
stellen uns weil sie gegenseitig fünf
fragen die dann jeweils der eine über
den anderen beantworten muss ein paar
sekunden später und zwar dass ihr meine
freundin
wir nehmen auf fünf fragen von jeweils
anderen raum ich meine erste frage an
dich martina bei mclaren sind
zusammengekommen
ja genau
du sagst willst du mich mal ansehen
ich sag ja ideen und treppen und kissen
und decken leben
seit dem film war richtig richtig erste
von citigroup
in ihrem video
martina wir haben unser erstes date
verbracht 221 nicht alles aber ich würde
sagen es halber punkt
ein kauf nicht mal diese schon die
richtig dreckigen victoria's secret
fliegen im rest der welt man konnte ja
nicht ob sie schwanger verriet die nati
schon vorbei aber ich beobachte im video
die dritte frage formieren wenig patina
die habe ich als erstes gekürzt
acht sprachen dass er zwei bis 22 die
drachen war herr werden helikopter für
539 dienstag mit
martina welche boxershorts trage ich am
meisten im bett bin ich mit ihr bin gar
keiner
aber die von dem richtig karibik in
einem team
genau einen lucia
karibik berlin am karibikstrand berlin
ich würde es nicht mehr und die weltraum
linken dritten 10 und rechts das was
jetzt hier vom video meine damen und
herren es euch gefallen hat will ich
mich eine wertung freuen
ich habe gehört dass mit mir geredet ich
hab mit mit martina mit einer freundin
video aufgenommen als optiker ich habe
auch gerade mit lucy einst kanal
aufgenommen uci ja okay da ist schon
allein ja schon link das mit
ok lake befindet beschreibung für max
kann darauf also gesteckt das ab das ist
was er beschreibe das video des start
ups